ASSEMBLY MEMBER MAIENSCHEIN
NOTICES THE ABSENCE OF A QUORUM.
THE SERGEANTS AT ARMS WILL
PREPARE THE CHAMBER BRING IN THE
ABSENT MEMBERS AND THE CLERK
WILL CALL THE ROLL [inaudible]
AGUIAR-CURRY ARAMBULA.
BAUER-KAHAN.
BERMAN BIGELOW.
BLOOM BURNER HORVATH
[inaudible]
BONTA [inaudible]
BRO [inaudible]
BURKE [inaudible]
CALDERON CARILLO CERVANTES CHAU.
CHEN.
DAVID CHIU.
CHOI.
KANSEN CHU COOLEY COOPER.
CUNNINGHAM DALY.
DAILY [inaudible]
DEEP [inaudible]
EGGMAN FLORA FONG FRAZIER
FRIEDMAN GABRIEL.
GALLAGHER CRISTINA GARCIA.
EDUARDO GARCIA.
GIPSON GLORIA GONZALEZ IS GRAY.
GRAYSON HOLDEN.
IRWIN JONES SAWYER.
KALRA KAMLAGER-DOVE.
KILEY.
LACKEY WIEN Là MON.
LOW.
MAIENSCHEIN MATHIS MAYES MCCARTY
MEDINA MELENDEZ MULLIN
MURATSUCHI [inaudible]
IN OBERNOLTE O'DONNELL PATTERSON
PETRIE-NORRIS QUIRK QUIRK SILVA
RAMOS RAY IS THREE OF US ROBERT
RIVAS RODRIGUEZ RUBIO.
SALAS SANTIAGO SMITH
[inaudible]
STONE.
TING VOEPEL.
WALDRON WEBER WICKS WOOD MISTER
SPEAKER
.
MEMBERS A QUORUM IS PRESENT.
A QUORUM IS PRESENT IN THE
ASSEMBLY.
WE ASKED THAT OUR GUESTS AND
VISITORS IN THE REAR OF THE
CHAMBER AND IN THE GALLERY
PLEASE STAND FOR THE PRAYER.
TODAY'S PRAYER WILL BE OFFERED
BY OUR ASSEMBLY CHAPLAIN THE
REVEREND BOB OSHITA REVENUES.
TO PLEASE JOIN ME IN A MOMENT OF
REFLECTION.
I'D LIKE TO SHARE A WARM MEMORY
THAT CAME TO MIND JUST YESTERDAY.
I RECALLED IN AFTERNOON WHEN I
WAS VISITING MY PARENTS IN SAN
FRANCISCO.
THIS WAS ABOUT TWENTY FIVE YEARS
AGO.
THEY WERE BOTH IN THEIR EIGHTIES
AND DRIVING LESS.
SOUL I ROUTINELY TOOK THEM TO
LUNCH WHEN I VISITED.
AFTER ENJOYING A MEAL AT A
RESTAURANT THEY BOTH LIKE.
I ACCEPTED THE BILL FROM OUR
WAITER.
WHEN I MOVED TO STAND MY EVER
SHARP MOTHER EXCITEDLY SAID?
DADDY HE'S GOING TO PAY FOR
LUNCH DON'T LET HIM.
MY FATHER CALMLY PLACED HIS HAND
IN ON MINE KEEPING ME AT THE
TABLE.
HE LEAVES REALLY BROUGHT OUT HIS
WALLET.
GAVE ME A CREDIT CARD AND SAID
PLEASE USE THIS FOR LUNCH.
I NODDED YES AND AGAIN.
BEGAN TO STAND.
MY EVER INTUITIVE MOTHER SAID NO
DANTE YOU HAVE TO GO WITH HIM OR
ELSE HE WON'T USE IT.
MY DAD AGAIN GENTLY PLACES HAND
ON MINE KEEPING ME AT THE TABLE.
THEN TALKING TO MY MOM HE SOFTLY
SAID MOMMY.
I ASKED MY SON TO USE MY CARD TO
PAY FOR LUNCH.
HE SAID HE WOULD.
I TRUST HIM.
THEN HE LOOKED AT ME AND SAID
WILL TAKE CARE OF THE BILL NOW.
WHEN I USED DAD'S CARD TO PAY
FOR LUNCH?
I FELT LIKE I WAS FIVE YEARS OLD
AGAIN.
EVEN NOW I SMILE AS I RECALL HIS
GENTLE STRENGTH.
THAT WAS THE QUIETLY POWERFUL
MOMENT I'LL NEVER FORGET.
IT WAS THE MOMENT THAT WHEN I
REALIZED IT BEING WORTHY OF MY
FATHER'S TRUST.
HAD BEEN AN UNSHAKABLE PART OF
ME FROM CHILDHOOD.
ALTHOUGH MY DAD DIED TWENTY
YEARS AGO.
BEING WORTHY OF HIS TRUST IS AN
HONOR I CARRY WITH ME STILL.
BEING WORTHY OF ANY TRUST IS AN
HONOR WE EACH AND EVERY DAY.
IT IS A REFLECTION OF OUR
INTEGRITY AND IT DEFINES OUR
CHARACTER.
LET US BE FOREVER GRATEFUL FOR
THE LOVING FAMILY MENTORS AND
FRIENDS.
THAT HAVE MORE THAN OUR
CHARACTER AND MEET US WORTHY OF
GENUINE TRUST.
NUMBER.
ONE WITH KINDNESS AND GRATITUDE
BEYOND WORDS.
THANK YOU REVEREND WE ASK OUR
GUESTS AND VISITORS TO REMAIN
STANDING AND JOIN US FOR THE
FLAG SALUTE PLEASE JOIN ASSEMBLY
MEMBER READ THIS.
AS HE LEADS US IN THE PLEDGE
MISTER REED.
READY [inaudible]
BEGIN.
HI OF THE STATE OF AMERICA --
STANDS --
ONE IS A LITTLE.
LESS.
THANK YOU MAY BE SEATED.
READING OF THE PREVIOUS DAY'S
JOURNAL.
ASSEMBLY CHAMBER SACRAMENTO
WEDNESDAY FEBRUARY THIRTEENTH
TWENTY NINETEEN RECENTLY MET AT
SEVEN AM ON REAL STEVEN S. CHOI
ASSEMBLY MEMBER SIXTY EIGHTH
DISTRICT PRESIDING CHEAPER
DEDUCTIBLES AND AT THE DASH
JUROR GLORIA MOVES AND MISS ROW
SECONDS.
THAT THE READING OF THE PREVIOUS
DAY'S JOURNAL BE DISPENSED WITH.
PRESENTATIONS AND PETITIONS
THERE ARE NONE.
INTRODUCTION REFERENCE TO BILLS
WILL BE DEFERRED.
REPORTS OF COMMITTEES WILL BE
DEEMED READ AND AMENDMENTS
DEEMED ADOPTED.
MESSAGES FROM THE GOVERNOR THERE
ARE NONE.
MESSAGES FROM THE SENATE THERE
MOVING TO MOTIONS AND
RESOLUTIONS.
ABSENCES FOR THE DAY FOR
PERSONAL BUSINESS ASSEMBLY
MEMBER JAY OBERNOLTE. FOR
ILLNESS ASSEMBLY MEMBERS BONTA.
AND CALLED AROUND.
MOVING TO PROCEDURAL MOTIONS
MISTER GLORIA.
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED FOR YOUR
PROCEDURAL MOTION SIR.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER I
REQUEST UNANIMOUS CONSENT TO
SUSPEND ASSEMBLY RULE FORTY FIVE
POINT FIVE ALLOW ASSEMBLYMEMBER
AGUIAR-CURRY AND GLORIA TO SPEAK
ON A GERMAN IN MEMORY TODAY.
WITHOUT OBJECTION SUCH SHALL BE
THE ORDER
.
MEMBERS WE HAVE GUESTS WITH US
IN THE ASSEMBLY CHAMBER TODAY.
YOUR MAIENSCHEIN I BELIEVE YOU
HAVE GAS MEMBERS.
THESE YOUR ATTENTION MR
MAIENSCHEIN.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER AND
MEMBERS TODAY IS RARE DISEASE
DAY NEARLY FOUR MILLION
CALIFORNIANS HAVE A RARE DISEASE
AND HALF OF RARE DISEASE
PATIENTS ARE CHILDREN.
A THIRD OF WHOM WILL NOT LIVE TO
REACH THEIR FIFTH BIRTHDAY WITH
THE SUPPORT OF THE CALIFORNIA
ACTION LATE FOR RARE DISEASES
KNOWN AS CAL RARE.
I ALONG WITH MY COLLEAGUES THE
LEGISLATIVE RARE DISEASE CAUCUS
TO BRING PUBLIC IN LEGISLATIVE
AWARENESS TO RARE DISEASES.
AND ENSURE PATIENTS HAVE A VOICE
IN SHAPING POLICY.
MEMBERS OF THE RARE DISEASE
COMMUNITY ARE AT THE CAPITOL
TODAY TO RAISE AWARENESS FOR
MORE THAN THAT SEVEN THOUSAND
KNOWN RARE DISEASES AND THOSE
THAT REMAIN UNDIAGNOSED.
PLEASE WELCOME ANGELA RAMIREZ
HOMES AND KIM MOONEY FROM CAL
RARE.
AND AN ASSET TO A POOL LOAN FROM
NATIONAL ORGANIZATION FOR RARE
DISEASES CALIFORNIA WILL
CONTINUE TO BE A LEADER ON THIS
IMPORTANT PUBLIC POLICY.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER
.
AND MS RAY YES.
I BELIEVE YOU HAVE SPECIAL
GUESTS IN THE GALLERY TODAY YOU
ARE RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER AND
MEMBERS.
I WOULD LIKE TO INTRODUCE TO YOU
THE BRIGHTEST YOUNG HIGH
SCHOOLERS.
AND ASSEMBLY DISTRICT FORTY
SEVEN THESE ARE YOU MY YOUNG
LEGISLATORS WE BROUGHT UP.
TWENTY NINE OF OUR STUDENTS.
THEY WILL BE SPENDING TIME HERE
IN THE CAPITAL DOING TOURS
VISITING WITH MEMBERS VISITING
WITH FELLOWS AND OTHER STAFFERS.
TO LEARN MORE ABOUT THE
LEGISLATIVE PROCESS.
THEM VERY HAPPY TO HAVE THE WIND
HERE WITH ME AND LIKE YOU ALL TO
JOIN ME IN WELCOMING THEM HERE
TO THE STATE CAPITOL
.
MEMBERS WE ARE MOVING TO
BUSINESS ON THE DAILY FILE.
SECOND READING CIRCLE RATE.
ASSEMBLY BILL ONE SIXTY NINE
WITH THE MOMENTS AND TWO FIFTEEN
WITH AMENDMENTS.
ALL BILLS WITHIN READ AND
AMENDMENTS ADOPTED.
MEMBERS WE ARE MOVING WE HAVE
ONE ITEM ON CONCURRENCE.
THIS IS CONCURRENCE FILE ITEM
NUMBER.
THREE THIS IS FILE ITEM NUMBER
THREE AB ONE FORTY NINE CLERK
WILL READ.
AS SOME PEOPLE ONE FORTY NINE
VICE ONLY MEMBER COOPER AND
OTHERS AND ACTUALLY TO
CONTROLLED SUBSTANCES DECLARING
THE URGENCY THERE UP TO TAKE
EFFECT IMMEDIATELY.
MEMBERS.
IS YOUR INTENTION TO MISTER
COOPER MISSED COULD BE A
RECOGNIZED THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER MEMBERS SYNONYMOUS TO AB
ONE FORTY NINE CORRECT A
SPELLING ERROR.
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE.
THINGS COOPER SEEING NO
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON THE ITEM.
CARPOOL OF THE ROLE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WE DESIRE TO
VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS OUT OF EL
[inaudible]
CLICK WELL [inaudible]
CLOSE ROLE.
TIED ABOUT EYES SEVENTY NO ZERO
SENATE AMENDMENTS.
ARE CONCURRED IN.
MEMBERS WE ARE MOVING TO THE
THIRD READING FILE.
THE FILE ITEM NUMBER FOUR PASS
AND RETAIN WE ARE GOING TO TAKE
UP FILE ITEM NUMBER.
FIVE THIS IS.
HR THIRTEEN BY.
MISTER KANSEN CHU CLERK WILL
READ.
HOUSE RESOLUTION THIRTEEN BY
SOMETHING MEMBER KANSEN CHU AND
OTHERS RELATIVE TO CALIFORNIA
GIRLS AND WOMEN IN SPORTS DAY.
MR CHU ON THE RESOLUTION.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER SAM
MEMBERS TODAY I'M PRESENTING H.
R. THIRTEEN WHICH DECLARED THE%
FIRST WEDNESDAY.
IN FEBRUARY AS CALL THE PHONE
YEAR OLD GIRLS AND WOMEN IN
SPORTS DAY.
THE FIRST NATIONAL GIRLS AND
WOMEN IN SPORTS DAY WAS IN HONOR
OF FLORIDA.
HYMAN --
BOTHER BALL A LEGEND FROM LOS
ANGELES SINCE AFFLECK AND THAT
ACTIVIST AND EVEN ADDRESS
STARRING IN AN ACTION ADVENTURE
MOVIE.
HR CERTEON IS OUR TRUE BILL TO
FLOYD AND THE THOUSANDS OF GIRLS
AND WOMEN WHO ARE ABLE TO PLAY
THE SPORTS THEY LOVE.
WOODS ALL GREEN TOLD NOTE JUST
BECAUSE OF THEIR GENDER.
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE AND WOULD REQUEST AT THE
FIRST WILL BE OPEN FOR CO AUTHOR.
YOU MAY MISTER ISSUE MISS BROWN
HORROCKS YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER MEMBERS
I'M PROUD TO STAND AS A CO
AUTHOR OF HR THIRTEEN TODAY WHEN
I THINK THE AUTHOR FOR BRING
THIS IMPORTANT RESOLUTION --
AS YOU KNOW HAVING WOMEN AND
GIRLS IN SPORTS IS A SIGN OF
EQUITY AND QUALITY.
AND TWENTY EIGHTEEN LAST YEAR
THE STATE LANDS COMMISSION --
ACTUALLY DETERMINED THAT THE
MAVERICKS SURF CONTEST WOULD
ALSO INCLUDE MEN AND ALSO HAVE
EQUAL COMPENSATION PRIZES FOR
MEN AND WOMEN.
THIS YEAR WE'VE INTRODUCED AB
FOR SIXTY SEVEN TO CODIFY THAT
GENDER EQUALITY IN SPORTS
BECAUSE WHERE WOMEN AND GIRLS
SEE.
THAT WE HAVE EQUITY IN OUR
PUBLIC LANDS WE ARE DOING A
SERVICE TO OUR COMMUNITY AND
THIS RESOLUTION IS IMPORTANT AS
WELL ALL THE THINGS ARE GOING TO
DO. TO MAKE SURE THE WOMEN AND
GIRLS OF CALIFORNIA LOOK TO US
AND THEY KNOW THEY'RE ASSEMBLY
MEMBERS HAVE THEIR BACK THANK
YOU VERY MUCH I CAN RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU MS BOERNER HORVATH.
SEEING NO ADDITIONAL DISCUSSION.
ON THE RESOLUTION.
THE AUTHORS ASKING THAT FIRST
ROLE BE OPEN FOR CO AUTHORS ON
THE RESOLUTION CLERK WILL OPEN
THE ROLE.
MEMBERS THIS IS FOR CO AUTHORS.
THIS IS CO AUTHORS.
ON HR THIRTEEN THIS IS FOR CO
AUTHORS [inaudible]
CLICK WELL.
CLOSER ALL.
THERE ARE SEVENTY FOUR CO
AUTHORS AT ON THE RESOLUTION AND
WITHOUT OBJECTION WE MAY TAKE A
VOICE VOTE.
ALL THOSE IN FAVOR SAY AYE.
AYE OPPOSED SAY NAY.
THE EYES HAVE IT THAT RESOLUTION
IS ADOPTED.
MEMBERS WE ARE AT FILE ITEM
NUMBER SIX THIS IS AJ ARE.
FOR CORPORATE.
ASSEMBLY DRINK RESOLUTION FOR BY
SOME REMEMBER AGUIAR-CURRY AND
OTHERS RELATIVE TO FIREARMS.
THIS AGUIAR-CURRY.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER MEMBERS
URGES CONGRESS TO SWIFTLY PASS
HOUSE RESOLUTION EIGHT THE
BIPARTISAN BACKGROUND CHECKS ACT
OF TWO THOUSAND NINETEEN HERE IN
CALIFORNIA WE HAVE ALREADY
PASSED LAWS TO REQUIRE UNIVERSAL
BACKGROUND CHECKS WITHOUT ANY
LOOPHOLES.
THIS LAW HELPS REDUCE THE
TRAGEDY IS GUN VIOLENCE BY
KEEPING FIRE ARMS OUT OF THE
HANDS OF THOSE WHO SHOULD NOT
HAVE THEM.
HOWEVER UNTIL WE BRING THIS
EFFECTIVE FIREARM POLICY TO THE
WHOLE COUNTRY A DANGEROUS
LOOPHOLE IN FEDERAL GUN LAWS
STILL EXEMPTS UNLICENSED SELLERS
FROM HAVING TO REFORM ANY
BACKGROUND CHECKS WHAT SO.
BEFORE SELLING A FIREARM.
THE MOST COMPREHENSIVE APPROACH
TO ENSURING THAT GUNS ARE NOT
SOLD TO PROHIBITED PEOPLE IS
THROUGH A NATIONAL UNIVERSAL
BACKGROUND CHECKS.
AT THE POINT OF TRANSFER OF ANY
FIREARM.
BY PASSING AJ OUR FOR OUR
CALIFORNIA LEADERS IN CONGRESS
AND OUR PRESIDENT WILL RECEIVE
THE MESSAGE LOUD AND CLEAR THE
CALIFORNIA FORMALLY A PUB
PUBLICLY DEMANDS THE SPEEDY
PASSAGE.
OF SIGNING OF H. R. EIGHT I ASK
FOR YOUR AYE VOTE.
THEY RESIDE HERE HURRY MISS
MELENDEZ HERE RECOGNIZE.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER.
LAYS IN GERMAN I RISE TODAY IN
OPPOSITION TO THIS AJ OUR FOR A
NUMBER OF REASONS --
LET ME START OFF BY READING TO
YOU PERMISSION TO READ MISTER
SPEAKER WITHOUT OBJECTION THANK
YOU.
ARE READ TO YOU THE COMMENTS
FROM THE CHAIRMAN OF THE
NATIONAL COUNCIL TO CONTROL HE
IN GUNS.
WHICH THEN CHANGED TO HANDGUN
CONTROL INC WHICH IS NOW THE
BRADY CAMPAIGN TO PREVENT GUN
VIOLENCE.
HIS WORDS WERE I AM CONVINCED
THAT WE HAVE TO HAVE FEDERAL
LEGISLATION TO BUILD ON WE'RE
GOING TO HAVE TO TAKE IT ONE
STEP AT A TIME.
AND THE FIRST STEP IS
NECESSARILY GIVEN THE POLITICAL
REALITIES GOING TO BE VERY
MODEST RIGHT NOW THOUGH WE BE
SATISFIED WITH HOW BELOW WITH
NOT HALF A LOAF BUT A SLICE.
ARE ULTIMATE GOAL TOTAL CONTROL
OF HANDGUNS IN THE UNITED STATES
IS GOING TO TAKE TIME.
THAT'S THE GOAL [inaudible]
I'M [inaudible]
SECOND.
I DON'T UNDERSTAND HOW THIS IS
EVEN GOING TO BE ENFORCEABLE.
WHO IS GOING TO GO OUT THERE AND
MAKE SURE THAT PEOPLE AREN'T
TRANSFERRING?
THEIR HAND GUNS WITHOUT GOING
THROUGH AN FFL.
IS ONE FORSMAN GONNA GO KNOCK ON
EVERYONE'S STORE I DON'T I DON'T
EVEN SEE HOW THIS IS ENFORCEABLE.
THIRD THIS BILL DOESN'T COVERS
STOCKING.
WHICH SHOULD FRIGHTEN EVERY
WOMAN IN HERE.
ANY MAN IN HERE IS A SISTER A
MOTHER OR DAUGHTER DOESN'T COVER
STOCKING.
THE BILL SAYS THAT IT'S IT THERE
IS AN EXEMPTION FOR THOSE WHO
FEEL THAT THEY ARE IN IN IN NEAR
OR IMMINENT DANGER BUT ONLY FOR
THE AMOUNT OF TIME.
THAT.
THEY ARE ACTUALLY IN NEAR --
IMMINENT DANGER WHAT WHO IS THE
JUDGE OF THAT.
WHEN I WAS ABOUT? TWO YEARS OLD
MAYBE YOUNGER THAN.
TO MY PARENTS WERE GOING THROUGH
A DIVORCE.
MY FATHER WAS VERY ABUSIVE TO MY
MOTHER OKAY [inaudible]
HE WHEN THEY WERE LIVING IN A
SEPARATE HOUSEHOLD --
IN HE WENT HE'S WAITING FOR HER
AT HER CAR ACTUALLY IN THE
MORNING.
BEFORE SHE WAS GOING TO WORK.
AND TOLD HER.
THAT HE WAS COMING AFTER HER HE
WAS GONNA KILLER.
THERE'S NO ONE THERE TO WITNESS
IT.
NO PROOF RIGHT.
SO SHE GOES TO WORK.
SHE KNOWS HE'S VIOLENCE BECAUSE
YOU KNOW HE'S HE'S ALREADY BEEN.
VIOLENT WITH THEIR IN THE PAST
TO SHE DECIDES TO GET HER
CHILDREN AFTER WORK AND GO TO
OUR IN LAWS HOUSE BECAUSE SHE
THINKS INNER HAD SURELY HE'S NOT
GOING TO HARM ME IN FRONT OF HIS
OWN PARENTS.
THERE SHE GOES OUR IN LAWS HOUSE
AND SHE PARKS HER CAR IN THEIR
GARAGE TO HE CAN'T SEE IT SO WE
CAN GO BY THERE.
AND AND FIND HER.
AND THAT EVENING HE FOUND HER HE
CAME TO THAT HELL NO MY IN LAWS
ARE HER IN LAWS EXCUSE ME
WEREN'T HOME AT THE TIME WHICH
HE PROBABLY KNEW.
SO HE GOES TO THE HOME.
AND HE GOES IN THERE AND START
HITTING HER AND STARTS SCREAMING
AT HER AND STARTS THREATENING
HER.
ANY BACKS ARE AGAINST THE WALL.
ANY PUTS HIS HAND ON HER THROAT.
AND STARTS CHOKING HER.
HE WAS SMART ENOUGH TO GO TO
THAT HOUSE.
WHEN HE KNEW HIS PARENTS WERE
GOING TO BE THERE?
WHEN HE WASN'T SMART ENOUGH TO
DO IS TO REALIZE THAT MY MOTHER
HAD ASKED A FRIEND AT WORK THE
ONLY PERSON SHE KNEW?
WHO OWNED A FIREARM IF SHE COULD
BORROW THEIR WEAPONS?
AND SHE DID AND THAT WALL THAT
HE HAD HER AGAINST RIGHT NEXT TO
THE TV IN THE TV STAND SHE PUT
THAT GUY RIGHT THERE BEHIND THAT
TELEVISION WHEN HE HAD HER
AGAINST THE WALL.
AND SHE ALMOST PASSED OUT SHE
REACHED BACK THERE AND GRAB THAT
GUN.
SHE DIDN'T SHOOT HIM.
BUT IT WAS ENOUGH. TO MAKE HIM
LEAVE TO MAKE HIM RUN BECAUSE
THAT'S WHAT POWER DO.
BUT IT SAVED HER LIFE.
I AGREE WITH YOU.
WE WANT TO KEEP GUNS OUT OF THE
HANDS OF PEOPLE LIKE THAT.
AND WE HAVE WAYS TO DO THAT AND
WE CAN WORK ON OTHER WAYS TO
MAKE SURE THAT DOESN'T HAPPEN.
BUT THIS RESOLUTION MEANS THAT
PEOPLE LIKE MY MOM.
LIKELY WOULD HAVE BEEN KILLED.
THAT'S NOT THE ANSWER.
AND I WANT TO WORK WITH YOU ON
THIS ISSUE BUT PLEASE DON'T PUT
WOMEN.
IN SITUATIONS LIKE MY MOM WAS IN
DON'T PUT THEIR LIVES IN
JEOPARDY PLEASE.
I WOULD ORIGINAL VOTE.
THANK YOU MISS MELENDEZ.
SEEING NO ADDITIONAL DISCUSSION
ON THE RESOLUTION.
MS SAGER KERR YOU MAY CLOSE WE
WISH.
I SIMPLY ASK YOUR AYE VOTE IN
JUST AS A REMINDER THIS IS TO
HAVE A PURPOSE A DANGEROUS
LOOPHOLE THAT WE HAVE IN FEDERAL
GUN LAW THAT EXEMPTS UNLICENSED
SELLERS.
FROM HAVING TO PERFORM ANY
BACKGROUND CHECK WHATSOEVER
BEFORE SELLING A FIREARM.
THANK YOU.
I AM IS AGUIAR-CURRY WOULD YOU
LIKE CO AUTHORS ON THE AJ ARE
YES I WOULD THANK YOU MEMBERS OF
FIRST ROLE IS GOING TO BE OPEN
FOR CO AUTHORS ON THE RESOLUTION
CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLE.
MEMBERS THIS IS FOR CO AUTHORS.
ON A CHAIR FOR THIS IS FOR CO
AUTHORS.
CO AUTHORS ADDING ON THE
RESOLUTION.
THIS IS FOR CO AUTHORS CLERK
WILL.
CLOSE THE ROLE THERE ARE FIFTY
FIVE CO AUTHORS ADDED THIS IS AJ
ARE SO WE WILL TAKE A ROLL CALL.
VOTE ON THE ITEM CLERK WILL OPEN
THE ROLE.
MEMBERS WISH TO VOTE ALL MEMBERS
VOTER WHICH TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTER WISHED ABOUT
[inaudible]
CLARK WELL.
CLOSE ROLL TIDE ABOUT.
ICE FIFTY EIGHT KNOWS FOURTEEN
THAT RESOLUTION IS ADOPTED.
MEMBERS NOW WE'RE MOVING.
TO SENATE THIRD READING.
JUST ONE ITEM ON SENATE THIRD
READING THIS IS.
FILE ITEM NUMBER.
SEVEN SB ONE TWENTY SIX
CORPORATE.
SENATE BILL ONE TWENTY SIX BY
SENATOR LEYVA AND OTHERS AND
ACTUALLY TO CHARTER SCHOOLS.
MISTER O'DONNELL.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER I RISE
TO PRESENT SB ONE TWENTY SIX
WHICH IS A GOOD GOVERNMENT BILL.
THAT TAKES A BOUNCE APPROACH AND
HAS BEEN AS THEY HAD MUCH
STAKEHOLDER INPUT.
IT APPLIES GOOD GOVERNMENT LOST
A CHARTER SCHOOL OPERATIONS BY
CLARIFYING THAT THE SAME
CONFLICT OF INTEREST
REQUIREMENTS THAT CURRENTLY
APPLY TO SCHOOL DISTRICTS.
ARE EXTENDED TO CHARTER SCHOOLS.
THIS BILL SEEKS TO ENSURE THAT
THE USE OF OUR PRECIOUS FEW
PUBLIC SCHOOL DOLLARS ARE
SUBJECT TO TRANSPARENCY.
COMMON ETHICAL PRACTICES AND
GOOD AS APPLIED TO OTHER
GOVERNMENTAL OPERATIONS IN
CALIFORNIA.
THE CALIFORNIA ATTORNEY AS A TO
THE CALIFORNIA ATTORNEY GENERAL
HAS VERY RECENTLY.
OPINED THAT THESE LAWS DO APPLY
TO CHARTER SCHOOLS BUT THIS BILL
SEEKS.
TO CLARIFY THAT THIS MEASURE IS
SUPPORTED BY MANAGEMENT LABOR
AND CIVIL JUSTICE ORGANIZATIONS
THE CHARTER SCHOOL ASSOCIATION
REMAINS NEUTRAL.
AND USE THIS AS A BALANCED
APPROACH.
THE BILL ENJOYED BIPARTISAN
SUPPORT IN THE SENATE I URGE YOU
TO SUPPORT THIS CRITICAL MEASURE.
TO PROTECT ALL OF OUR PUBLIC
SCHOOLS AND OUR PUBLIC DOLLARS.
AND I WANT TO THANK MY COLLEAGUE
FROM RIVERSIDE FOR HIS WORK ON
THIS EFFORT AS WELL.
THANK YOU MISTER O'DONNELL
MISTER MEDINA.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER AND
MEMBERS I RISE TODAY IN SUPPORT
AS A PROUD TEACHER.
IN SUPPORT OF SENATE BILL.
ONE TWENTY SIX THE BILL THAT
INSPIRES TO INCREASE
TRANSPARENCY AND ACCOUNTABILITY
AND CALIFORNIA'S CHARTER SCHOOLS.
AS I TRAVEL TO HAMILTON HIGH
SCHOOL A FEW WEEKS AGO DURING
THE LA TEACHERS STRIKE.
I HEARD THE VOICES OF THE
TEACHERS THE STUDENTS AND THE
PARENTS.
ARE CHARTER SCHOOLS HAVE BECOME
A DRAIN.
ON PUBLIC SCHOOLS.
WE SEE CONSTANTLY IN THE NEWS
THE MISS DEALINGS AND CONFLICTS
OF INTEREST.
ARISING IN CHARTER SCHOOLS.
SB ONE TWENTY SIX LIKE BILLS
BEFORE IT LAST YEAR AND SEVERAL
YEARS BEFORE.
RECOGNIZES THE ISSUES WITH
CHARTER SCHOOLS AND DELIVERS ON
THE LONG NEEDED TRANSPARENCY THE
TEACHERS STUDENTS AND PARENTS
HAVE BEEN ASKING.
FOR SO I APPLAUD THE GOVERNOR'S
OFFICE LEADERSHIP IN BOTH HOUSES
FOR FINALLY PUTTING THIS ISSUE
TO REST.
AND RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR
AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU MISTER MEDINA MISS
SMITH YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER.
MEMBERS IN COLLEAGUES I RISE
TODAY IN SUPPORT OF SB ONE
TWENTY SIX I THINK MY COLLEAGUES
IN THE CHAMBER FOR THEIR WORK ON
THIS IMPORTANT MATTER.
BUT I RISE AS A NINE YEAR MEMBER
OF IN A WHERE WE WERE TASKED ON
A REGULAR BASIS WITH THE
CHALLENGES OF BEING COMPLETELY
TRANSPARENT. TO THE TAXPAYERS
AND THE FAMILIES THAT WE SERVED
IN MY COMMUNITY.
WE ARE AT A CROSSROADS IN OUR
PUBLIC EDUCATION SYSTEM WE KNOW
THAT CONTINUOUS IMPROVEMENT IS
REQUIRED AND THE MOMENT IS NOW
FOR US TO SEIZE ON EVERY
OPPORTUNITY. TO FIND MEASURES OF
BEST PRACTICE IN FISCAL
MANAGEMENT AND IN STUDENT
OUTCOMES THIS MEASURE IS AN
IMPORTANT FIRST STEP IN ENSURING
THAT WE INTEGRATE THE CHARTER
SCHOOL MEMBERS.
INTO THAT PROCESS WITH US THAT
WE PROVIDE THEM OPPORTUNITIES
FOR GOOD GOVERNANCE THAT WE SEEK
TO SEE THEIR WORK IN THE PUBLIC
FORUM.
AND LEARN FROM IT SO MEMBERS AND
COLLEAGUES I URGE YOUR SUPPORT
FOR THIS MEASURE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MISS SMITH SINGLE
ADDITIONAL DISCUSSION OR DEBATE
ON THE ITEM.
MISTER DALI MAY CLOSE ASPIRIN
I'VE OFFICER SPEAKER.
QUICKLY OVER THERE ALL.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE.
DESIRE TO VOTE ON MEMBERS VOTED
IS THERE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS OF A RESERVE A ALL
MEMBERS REYES OUT OF THE CLERK
WILL.
CLOSER ALL TIED ABOUT AYE.
SIXTY THREE KNOWS NINE THAT
MEASURE PASSES.
MEMBERS WE WILL NOW MOVE TO THE
SECOND A CONSENT CALENDAR THERE
ARE RESOLUTIONS ON TODAY'S
CONSENT CALENDAR.
BEFORE WE VOTE ON THE CONSENT
CALENDAR ITSELF WE WILL FIRST
TAKE UP RESOLUTIONS THAT ARE ON
CONSENT FOR THE PURPOSE.
OF ADDING CO AUTHORS.
WITHOUT OBJECTION WILL TAKE ONE
ROLL CALL VOTE AND ALLOW ANY
MEMBER TO ADD ON AS A CO AUTHOR.
TO THE RESOLUTIONS AND THE CLERK
WILL READ THE RESOLUTIONS ON
CONSENT.
ASSEMBLY CONCURRENT RESOLUTION
THIRTY FIVE BY SOMETHING NUMBER
CHOI IT RELATIVE TO YOU QUAN
SOON DAY.
AND HOUSE RESOLUTION SIXTEEN BY
SOMETHING OVER PETRIE-NORRIS
RELATIVE TO READ ACROSS AMERICA
DAY.
WORK WILL NOW OPEN THE ROLE TO
ALLOW ANY MEMBER TO ADD ON AS A
CO AUTHOR TO THESE RESOLUTIONS
PARK LIBERAL.
MEMBERS THIS IS FOR CALL AUTHORS.
THIS IS FOR CO AUTHORS
.
CLICK WELL CLOSER ALL.
THERE ARE SEVENTY FIVE CO
AUTHORS THE CLERK WILL APPLY
THAT VOTE TO THE RESOLUTIONS
THAT ARE ON TODAY'S [inaudible]
CONSENT CALENDAR.
MOVING NOW TO A VOTE ON THE
CONSENT CALENDAR CITY MEMBER
WHICH REMOVE AN ITEM FROM
CONSENT.
SEEING HEARING ON CLERK READ THE
SECOND EXECUTOR.
ASSEMBLY CONCURRENT RESOLUTION
THIRTY FIVE BY SOMETHING NUMBER
CHOI AND OTHERS RELATIVE TO YOU
ONCE IN DAY.
WORK WELL OVER THE ROLE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO WISH TO
VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTED WISHED ABOUT
THIS IS THE CONSENT CALENDAR.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE.
WISH TO VOTE.
CLICK WELL CLOSER ALL.
TODD ABOUT I SEVENTY FIVE NO
ZERO THE CONSENT CALENDAR IS
ADOPTED.
CLERK WILL READ THE REMAINING
ITEMS ON THE CONSENT CALENDAR.
HOUSE RESOLUTION.
SIXTEEN I SEVENTY FIVE NO.
ZERO SENATE CONCURRENT
RESOLUTION.
TEN I SEVENTY FIVE NO ZERO
SENATE CONCURRENT RESOLUTION
TWELVE I SEVENTY FIVE NO ZERO
AND SENATE CONCURRENT RELIGION
RESOLUTION.
FOURTEEN I SEVENTY FIVE NO.
ZERO MEMBERS MOVING BRIEFLY TO
ANNOUNCEMENTS.
ALL MEMBERS MEMBERS MAY HAVE
YOUR ATTENTION PLEASE ALL
MEMBERS MUST FILE THEIR ANNUAL
STATEMENT OF ECONOMIC INTEREST
FORMS BY FRIDAY.
MARCH FIRST.
NO TO FORM SEVEN HUNDRED MUST BE
SUBMITTED ELECTRONICALLY. TO THE
F. A. B. C. OR IT'S A HARD COPY
TO THE CHIEF CLERK ROOM.
THIRTY ONE NINETY SIX BY FIVE PM.
THIS DEADLINE IS FOR MEMBERS
DESIGNATED STAFF.
MUST FILE BY APRIL SECOND.
SESSION SCHEDULE IS AS FAR FIRST
OF FOR SESSION --
CHECK IN SESSION MONDAY MARCH
FOURTH FLOOR SESSION.
IS AT ONE PM.
IN THE ABSENCE OF OBJECTION
.
NEVER HAVE A CORRECTION MONDAY.
MARCH FOURTH IS OUR WOMAN OF THE
YEAR CELEBRATION [inaudible]
RECOGNITION.
AND THAT STARTS AT TWO PM NOT
ONE PM SO SESSION MONDAY.
STARTS AT TWO PM FOR THE SPECIAL
RECOGNITION OF AN MEMBERS IN THE
ABSENCE OF OBJECTION QUORUM CALL
IS LIFTED AND WE WILL NOW MOVE
TO PREVIOUSLY.
ANNOUNCED A GERMAN TO MEMORY.
MEMBERS PLEASE TAKE YOUR SEATS
OR TAKE YOUR CONVERSATIONS OFF
OF THE GREEN CARPET.
MEMBERS WHERE A GERMAN TO MEMORY
PLEASE TAKE YOUR SEATS.
OR TAKE YOUR CONVERSATIONS OFF
OF THE FLOOR
.
MEMBERS A QUORUM PLEASE.
REMAINING MEMBERS PLEASE TAKE
YOUR SEATS ON THE FLOOR PLEASE
TAKE YOUR SEATS MEMBERS
[inaudible]
MEMBERS.
THE PREVIOUSLY ANNOUNCED
ADJOURNMENTS [inaudible]
IN MEMORY.
THE MEMBERS WERE GRANTED PRIOR
PERMISSION TO SPEAK ON
ADJOURNMENTS IN MEMORY.
MS AGUIAR-CURRY YOUR RECOGNIZE
YOUR DESK.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER AND
MEMBERS.
I RISE TODAY TO JR IN MEMORY OF
HARY PRICE A VISIONARY
PRESERVATIONISTS DEVELOPER AND
FRIEND TO SO MANY.
HURRY PEACEFULLY PASSED AWAY IN
HIS SLEEP AT THE AGE OF SEVENTY
SEVEN ON FEBRUARY TWELFTH.
UNASSUMING IN NATURE AND NEVER
SEEKING THE SPOTLIGHT WAS ONE OF
THE VISIONARIES WHO SAW DOWNTOWN
NAPA'S POTENTIAL BEFORE ANY
OTHERS DID AND HELPED CREATE.
THE NAPA RIVER FRONT WHICH HAS
BECOME A DESTINATION FOR LOCALS
AND VISITORS ALIKE.
HE HELPED LEAD COMMUNITY EFFORTS
IN THE REDESIGN OF PORTIONS OF
NAPA FLOOD CONTROL PROJECT WHICH
IS SAVE DOWNTOWN FROM FLOODING.
EVEN DURING OUR MOST RECENT
STORMS.
HE SAW THE POTENTIAL IN THE OLD
AND DILAPIDATED NAPA MILL
PROPERTY AND DEVELOPED IT INTO
THE NAPA RIVER IN.
A HOTEL IN MEETING CENTER THAT
HONORS THE COMMUNITIES PASSED.
THIS PROPERTY TRANSFER
TRANSFORMATION WAS A MAJOR
CONTRIBUTOR TO THE DOWNTOWN
NAPA'S TURN AROUND AND
RENAISSANCE.
AN ATTORNEY BY TRADE BETTER
PRESERVATIONISTS AND HISTORY
BUFF AT HEART.
HE IS DESCRIBED AS ONE OF
NAFTA'S TRUE HEROES AND
TREASURES A RISK TAKER WITH A
GOAL HEART OF GOLD ANNEKE AND
EXQUISITE SENSE OF QUIET
DIPLOMACY.
TERRY LEAVES BEHIND HIS WIFE
LINDA SON ADAM DAUGHTER IN LAW
AUTUMN GRANDDAUGHTER MILLIA AND
FOUR SIBLINGS.
MEMBERS I RESPECTFULLY REQUEST
THAT YOU JOIN ME IN THE JOINING
A JOURNEY IN THE MEMORY OF NAPA
COUNTIES GENTLE GIANT CAREY
PRICE.
THANK YOU MS AGUIAR-CURRY AND
MISTER GLORIA YOU ARE RECOGNIZED
FOR YOUR GERMAN MEMORY.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER I RISE
TODAY TO ASK THAT WE ADJOURN IN
THE MEMORY OF A TRAILBLAZING
EDUCATOR AND CIVIL RIGHTS
ACTIVISTS ARE MONDO RODRIGUEZ.
I'M UNDER RODRIGUEZ WAS BORN ON
SEPTEMBER THIRTIETH NINETEEN
TWENTY ONE AND GOMEZ PALAZZO
MEXICO.
WHEN HE WAS SIX YEARS OLD HE WAS
BROUGHT TO SAN DIEGO --
BY HIS PARENTS NOT KNOWING A
WORD OF AFTER BEING FORCED BACK
TO MEXICO AS A RESULT OF
DEPRESSION ERA DEPORTATIONS HIS
FAMILY RETURNED TO SAN DIEGO AND
SETTLED IN THE COMMUNITY OF
LOGAN HEIGHTS.
IN SCHOOL MANY OF HIS TEACHERS
WROTE HIM OFF AS ROWDY IN A SLOW
LEARNER.
DESPITE THIS MISTER RODRIGUEZ
BECAME THE FIRST IN HIS FAMILY
TO GRADUATE FROM HIGH SCHOOL.
WHEN THE JAPANESE BROUGHT BOMB
PEARL HARBOR HE LISTED IN UNITED
STATES ARMY HE SERVED DURING
WORLD WAR TWO AS A CRYPTOGRAPHER
DECODING CLASSIFIED MATERIALS?
AND BECAME A UNITED STATES
CITIZEN DURING THE WAR.
AFTER HIS SERVICE TO THE NATION
HE ENROLLED IN SANDY GO STATE
COLLEGE WHAT IS NOW KNOWN TODAY
SANDY WAS STATE UNIVERSITY.
WHERE HE EARNED A BA AND AN MA
IN EDUCATION AND RECEIVED HIS
TEACHING CREDENTIAL?
MISTER RODRIGUEZ THEN BEGAN
TEACHING AT MEMORIAL JUNIOR HIGH
SCHOOL ANY WORK TO IMPRESS UPON
HIS STUDENTS THE IMPORTANCE OF
STAYING IN SCHOOL.
IN NINETEEN FIFTY SEVEN HE
BECAME THE FIRST LATINO SCHOOL
ADMINISTRATOR WITHIN THE SANDIA
UNIFIED SCHOOL DISTRICT WHEN HE
ASSUMED THE ROLE OF VICE
PRINCIPAL AT GOMPERS JUNIOR HIGH
SCHOOL.
FROM THERE MISTER RODRIGUEZ WAS
APPOINTED CHIEF OF THE BUREAU OF
INTERGROUP RELATIONS OR OUR OWN
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
EDUCATION.
A LIFELONG DEMOCRAT MISTER
RODRIGUEZ IS ACTIVE IN MANY THE
VIVA KENNEDY CAMPAIGN IT WAS
CLOSELY INVOLVED WITH THE SAN
DIEGO DEMOCRATIC PARTY.
IN NINETEEN SIXTY TWO HE BECAME
THE FIRST MEXICAN AMERICAN TO
RUN FOR THE CALIFORNIA STATE
ASSEMBLY FROM SAN DIEGO.
HIS PASSION FOR POLITICS IN
EDUCATION INTERSECTED WHEN HE
WAS APPOINTED BY PRESIDENT
LYNDON JOHNSON TO HEAD THE
OFFICE OF SPANISH SPEAKING
AMERICAN AFFAIRS WHERE HE PUSHED
FOR BILINGUAL EDUCATION.
MISTER RODRIGUEZ WERE GONNA
SERVE THREE ADDITIONAL UNITED
STATES PRESIDENTS.
UNDER PRESIDENT NIXON HE SERVED
AS THE ASSISTANT COMMISSIONER OF
EDUCATION.
AND UNDER PRESIDENT CARTER --
HE WAS APPOINTED TO THE EQUAL
EMPLOYMENT OPPORTUNITY
COMMISSION ANY CONTINUE TO SERVE
IN THAT ROLE UNDER PRESIDENT
REAGAN.
IN NINETEEN SEVENTY THREE BECAME
THE FIRST LATINA PRESIDENT OF
EAST LOS ANGELES COLLEGE.
LAST WEEK ON FEBRUARY
SEVENTEENTH MISTER RODRIGUEZ
PASSED AWAY IN HIS HOME IN SAN
DIEGO.
HE WAS NINETY SEVEN YEARS OLD.
HE IS SURVIVED BY HIS WIFE OF
SEVENTY YEARS PATRICE.
HIS CHILDREN CHRISTIE AND ROD.
FOUR GRANDCHILDREN AND THREE
GREAT GRANDCHILDREN.
MISTER RODRIGUEZ AUTOBIOGRAPHY
ENTITLED FROM THE BARIO TO
WASHINGTON AND EDUCATORS JOURNEY
HE SAID.
THE HISTORY OF MY LIFE IS ONE OF
ALWAYS STRIVING TO MAKE IT UP
THE LADDER. ONE MORE STEP.
I ALWAYS HOPE HOPE TO HELP
OTHERS DO THE SAME.
IF I WAS SUCCESSFUL IN THIS IT
WAS BECAUSE MANY PEOPLE QUITE
UNLIKE ME.
HELPS.
I RESPECTFULLY ASK THAT WE
ADJOURN TODAY IN MEMORY OF
AMANDA RODRIGUEZ THANK YOU
MISTER SPEAKER.
THANK YOU MISS GLORIA.
NEVER SWEEPING THE NAMES TO THE
DEATH TO BE PRINT IN THE JOURNAL
ALL REQUEST WOULD TURN IN MEMORY
WILL BE DEEMED READ AND PRINTED
IN THE JOURNAL.
ALL OTHER ITEMS REMAINING WILL
BE PASSED TO RETAIN ALL MOTION
SHALL BE CONTINUE.
SEEING HER IN A FOR THE BUSINESS
I'M READY TO ENTERTAIN A MOTION
TO ADJOURN.
SHE GLORIA MOVES.
MISS RODRIGUEZ SECONDS AT THIS
HOUSE STANDS ADJOURNED UNTIL
MONDAY MARCH FOURTH AT TWO PM.
WE ARE ADJOURNED